president vladimir zelinski told the
world economic forum in davos
switzerland that russia
should face maximum economic sanctions
and a total trade embargo he said last
night that russia is waging what he
called total war on his country
deborah patton now spent time with a
private militia doing its part to
protect a ukrainian village from
invaders
now we are in the
action area silva kojimeko has become
adept at navigating the perilous roads
through ruskolozova move move move the
men of his charter battalion are
hunkered down across this devastated
village freed from occupation but still
in russia's firing line so this is our
first place
from where we started just a few months
ago he was a wealthy businessman now
he's using his millions to fund a
volunteer defense unit
we're off to the next base silver player
he's convinced ukraine has a clear
advantage in this war ukrainian people
are
different from russians in
one very important thing
ukrainians love freedom
our next stop is across an open road
it's more or less safe but you better
watch your step anyway two two pairs by
paris let's go it's cloudy yeah it's
cloudy it's good it's obscure the view
it's a quick sprint to avoid being
spotted by russian drones we all are
worried you think i'm do you think i am
not worried i'm also worried everybody's
worried here everybody's afraid
but if an army runs on its stomach this
one is doing very well
food and weapons prepped alongside each
other tonight it's fish it looks
delicious
it looks delicious
delicious
and we're off again do you run marathons
yeah three times
once in new york me too i also did the
new york marathon kojimako is dismissive
of russia's fighting capability are they
any good i mean before the war
russia had this reputation for being no
it's
one last quick stop this is the face of
this war
not machine guns not rifles
creatures
for cbs morning's debra patter ruska
lazova ukraine
powerful images happen to be armed while
you're eating deborah powder thank you